long ago queen marica and her consort  godfrey waged war against the fire  giants of the mountaintops apparently  like all wars that are waged in this  game it ends with no true victor queen  america realized that she could not  fully destroy the flame of the giants so  she instead cursed the last giant to  attend to the flame for all of eternity  the giant in turn cast a curse of his  own cursing marca with red hair just  like the fire giants to be rid of this  curse marcus split her body and soul  into two different entities using the  power of the elden ring this is why we  see queen marco rocking the hot blonde  locks and ratagon with the red hair of  the fire giant meaning that they're two  different sides of the same coin but  with their own individual consciousness